buenos días y justamente el margen de
maniobra estará dado por el apoyo que
consiga de las fuerzas a las que terminó
aliándose en primera instancia que son
pachakuti y les pierda democrática el
discurso de ayer dio buenas señales
porque intermón lazo se ubicó más en el
centro es decir en una derecha moderada
o un centro político iu y psoe e iu
soluciones a por ejemplo el crecimiento
macroeconómico pero al mismo tiempo
justicia social la lucha por la igualdad
de género por ejemplo el tema
ambientalista el tema de la desnutrición
infantil y todas las de emergencias
sociales que son demandas de esos
sectores que hasta ahora él han apoyado
para la elección de las autoridades en
la asamblea la presidencia de la
asamblea sobre todo en ese orden de
ideas entonces qué prioridades tendría
que tener el presidente lazo porque las
necesidades son muchas pero los recursos
son pocos y además debe tomar decisiones
rápidas y eso significa tener que
negociar
y las prioridades sin duda tienen que
ser cumplir con su plan de vacunación
que ha ofrecido en 90 días vacunar a 9
millones de personas o tratar de cumplir
de la mejor manera y luego afrontar el
tema del desempleo y el tema de la
desnutrición infantil que es un tema que
está preocupando y está digamos se ha
agudizado de una manera importante y las
demandas las demandas de la sociedad
civil y de estos sectores que
por ejemplo atraviesan también el tema
de la sociedad la seguridad social
perdón
y hacer una reforma que asegure la
seguridad social como un mecanismo de
solidaridad y de aseguramiento para los
jubilados y para los jóvenes que
empiezan a aportar desde ya
al sistema y como debe el presidente
lazo entonces balancear estas reformas
sobre todo en la materia económica que
es compleja en este país para que no
parezcan demasiado radicales en ecuador
también hay un descontento social por la
economía del país por la situación de la
pandemia
incluso en el 2019 hubo marchas
ciudadanas que llevaron a que el
presidente de turno tuviera que revertir
algunas decisiones que había tomado
justamente un equilibrio entre lo
macroeconómico como el ha mencionado la
apertura la apertura comercial al mundo
la entrada a la alianza del pacífico
pero al mismo tiempo no descuidar el
gasto social es decir no descuidar
políticas sociales para enfrentar la
crisis actual que preocupan y que
atienden las necesidades más urgentes de
quienes le dieron su voto en la segunda
vuelta
sofía cordero en la ciudad de quito
gracias por este análisis para la
audiencia de france 24 gracias por estar
con nosotros